الجزء الأول هو أنه لا يلزم أن يكون
فريدًا ، بل يحتاج إلى معالجة
مشكلة في السوق ، فهو ليس
الحل وليس الحل الذي
يجب أن يكون فريدًا فحسب ، بل يجب أن يكون أيضًا
مشكلة فريدة ويجب أن تكون كذلك
رائد أعمال واضح جدًا بشأن
المشكلة التي تحلها ومن هم
عملاؤك هم الجزء الآخر وربما يكون
الجزء الأكثر أهمية إذا سألتني في
المرحلة المبكرة هو هل لديك
المهارات الصحيحة ، هل لديك
التصميم كرائد أعمال  هل
لديك شغف لرؤية هذا وأنت
تعلم أن ريادة الأعمال هي
ركوب الأفعوانية ، فالأشياء لا تسير دائمًا في
طريقك ، ولا تسير في الاتجاه الصحيح أبدًا ، أنت تعلم
أنها رحلة فوضوية ويمكن أن
تكون رحلة وحشية كل سوق
فريد من نوعه.  كما تعلم ، أعتقد أن الكثير منا
قد ارتكب الخطأ خلال هذه
السنوات الثماني التي تعرفها بين دعونا نقول عام 2010 إلى
ما نحن فيه الآن ، أعتقد أننا ارتكبنا عدة
مرات خطأ
بمحاولة نسخ ولصقنا كمجتمع  لا يزال
لديها المرفقات ق  من تيغما إلى الفشل ونحن
نشعر بالحرج قليلاً للحديث
عن
رفضنا وإخفاقاتنا وصراعاتنا ، لكن إذا لم
نتحدث وهذه حقيقة إذا لم
نتحدث عنها فلن نحصل أبدًا
على فرصة لمعالجة  لهم والانتقال
منهم عندما بدأنا على يقين من أنني
سأقول أنه في كثير من الأحيان عندما نظرنا
إلى أحداثنا ومهرجاناتنا الملهمة ،
كان هناك عدد أكبر من النساء اللائي كن
يأتون أكثر من الرجال وعندما وصل الأمر
إلى مرحلة الفكرة كانوا لا يزالون أكثر من
النساء  من الرجال ولكن عندما يتعلق الأمر
بأخذ حواس هذه الفكرة وتحويلها
إلى عمل تجاري ، فقد فعلنا ذلك
وربما إلى حد ما ما زلنا
نشهد انخفاضًا في عدد النساء وأعتقد أن
هناك فجوة ثقة
الأمر متروك لنا  يقع العبء على عاتقنا
لمحاولة سد فجوة الثقة هذه وربما
منحهم المهارات التي يشعرون
أنهم يفتقدونها من أجل بناء هذا
النشاط التجاري
[الموسيقى]
لذلك كنت سأقول أن تكون أكثر ثقة
مع المضي قدمًا ماليًا لمدة 10 سنوات
من الان  آمل وأنا متأكد من أنني
سأستمر في تذكر رد الجميل
للمكان الذي أعطاني الكثير